a day of mixed emotions for moldovans
sadness and pride as they remembered
suffering and heroism in the second
world war
this was a soviet republic for decades
it's now torn between looking east and
west
moldova wants to join the european union
but russia does retain a lot of support
on these streets
some told us europe benefits from a
strong russia
others believe ukraine really is home to
a corrosive cabal of far-right fanatics
they are nazist they are nazis true
nazis
they did as many things that
never i i can't i can't
even imagine that this would happen
again
in our world
moldova has made it an offence to wear
the orange and black ribbon of saint
george a familiar sign of russian
affiliation but many either ignored that
or just wore orange and black clothes
instead this was a march to celebrate
war victory and remember war dead but it
was also loaded with signs of support
for russia whether that was hammer and
sickle soviet symbols or those orange
and black ribbons and items of clothing
or whether it's people telling us that
they truly believe that russia is trying
to de-nazify ukraine a country that lies
just over the border
moldova suffered horrendously in world
war ii many here remain terrified of
conflict proud that their nation is
avowedly neutral
we are neutral country this is our
constitution and we help ukrainian
people who are in need and
we don't want war on our charity
but others believe that precious
neutrality has gone
why else would the ribbons be banned or
the eu be courted and that worries them
we're not sure about the future of this
country we have hopes we have good hopes
but anyway
we
we see the government laws they
introduce
they are not neutral
everybody here understands it and
we will not we don't know what will
happen later the specter of russia does
loom large here a country with a soviet
past and an unpredictable future adam
parsons sky news krishna